a day after the first earthquake struck
there's still hope people have survived
buried in the rubble
the first Quake hit at 4 17 on Monday
morning most people would have been in
bed with no time to Run for Cover
this was a six-story block of flats in
San Luisa in Southeastern turkey rescue
teams must work quickly
but carefully
there were 53 people living in 12
Apartments here four were pulled out
alive
after the earthquake I called my
relatives to make sure they are okay
three of my uncles answered the phone
but one couldn't we buried him and his
wife today his daughter was rescued
alive but there are still three more
people from our family in the rubble
I think there are still 25 to 26 people
under the rubble I had two shops under
the building they were all destroyed
there is nothing to do but wait whatever
we had is gone hopefully the government
will help us
generally offer is 220 kilometers from
the epicenter of the first Quake most of
the buildings in the city of more than 2
million are still standing but the
government is worried many thousands of
structures have been dangerously
weakened this is just a small example of
the extraordinary humanitarian challenge
facing the Turkish authorities now this
scene is being repeated hundreds if not
thousands of times across this region so
severe is the crisis the government
faces that it's encouraging as many as
the 12 million people who live in the
affected area to try and get out it's
offering five dollar tickets on flight
out of here to the western part of
turkey and humanitarian flights that are
coming in will leave with people on them
who want to escape the region there is
now a state of emergency in this region
president reject type erdogan says the
area will be flooded with humanitarian
relief workers along with the foreign
rescue teams they need to get here
quickly because time is running out
Bernard Smith Al Jazeera shanlius in
Southeastern turkey